for our series the dish we took a trip
to an award-winning Jamaican restaurant
in Kingston not Kingston Jamaica that
would be Kingston New York where
Jamaican immigrants Albert and Melinda
Bartley opened top taste about eight
years ago it was a dream come true for
Albert in particular who had spent most
of his life working in a chemical plant
the couple told Vlad how they turned
their unassuming little restaurant into
a neighborhood Institution
for love into it you can taste it
for food filled with love what I want
yeah yeah
she already knows and the hospitality of
home I come here because it's a it's a
little piece of Home customers come from
far and wide to eat authentic Jamaican
food at Top Taste Restaurant in Kingston
New York it's run by married couple
Albert and Melinda Bartley refresh
with Bob Marley playing on the radio
they serve up dishes like curry goat and
jerk chicken with smiles but by the look
of the modest storefront tucked away two
blocks from the highway it might seem
easy to drive right past it but not for
62 year old Mr Bartley or Sammy as he's
known around here you know I feel the
same there you know on the building for
a sale for sale yeah and you thought
that's my restaurant yeah I'll be like I
think she must have that's a nice
location for a restaurant
he knew that that was where he would
open the restaurant he had dreamed of
owning since he immigrated to the U.S 40
years ago why did the building with the
for sale sign say to you you know what
this is the spot believe me I don't know
I believe me I don't believe it's just a
spirit of the almighty
and then the next day I call the bank
and that's it were you ever at one point
nervous that people wouldn't like
Jamaican Cuisine no never no
so he quit his job mixing chemicals at
the company where he worked for 33 years
and returned to the kitchen where his
grandmother first taught him the recipes
he cooks today
My grandmother used to always in the
kitchen are the menus in your head or
did your grandmother write them down or
what like the bread coconut rice and
beans well you know at first it was his
menu your menu yeah yeah and and I add
more
he didn't know that an opening Top Taste
he would also find a kindred spirit in
Melinda who had learned to cook from her
mom and it was in this restaurant where
they'd first meet so I came to see my
friend I lived up the road up there and
I was cooked dinner for her when she's
at work and one day I say I'm not
cooking you anything
there's no Jamaican restaurant around
here he said yes my friend has one I
said we're going
all right so tell me you walk through
the door I open the door
and he came over to me and said if I was
not dating someone I would
I would there it is and I said to myself
oh this man better not change his mind
let me let me quit my job and sell more
my stuff life is about Taking Chances
though you just never know
that risk paid off they built a family
together and made another one in their
Community welcoming in Neighbors from
the local police and fire departments to
high schoolers in 2020 Sammy was
nominated for the James Beard award for
best chef and in 2022 they were both
named semi-finalists for the same award
it was nice that they recognize us
because we really work hard and we put
our heart
into what we cook we anything we cook is
what we would serve our families we cook
with a lot of love and passion and it
shows I see my oxtail I see some curry
goat coconut curry shrimp that's like
our Fresh Veggies like a ginger vinegar
right on there okay and then um this
plantain is sweet it looks like sweet
plantains it is
oh man so tender
I know I should be talking through this
for the camera
[Laughter]
ingredients in in your food I said you
know it's love that is the main
ingredients because when you love what
you do and you love the person that you
work with it brings out so much in the
food that's right that's right yeah I
love his pickup line if I wasn't dating
I know I would date you and then she
said I'm quitting my job
it worked it worked look what they've
created so this is what we've got a
little jerk chicken we've got some
oxtails some patties and you got to try
that champagne Cola it's delicious uh
dig in I mean I love I love to do the
talking uh which one is the chicken this
is the oxtails right right this is good
right Cola the Patty's good too and
what's the meat in the in the Patty I
always like a good Jamaican Patty this
one's probably ground beef
oh man right why you always give me the
cheese to commercial it's like I want to
eat I want to eat I got to do my job but
this couple you know the restaurant is
situated in a great place they've got a
police station oh wait wait what is this
this is good making champagne Cola it's
actually very popular across the
Caribbean but every Caribbean country
makes its own makes a difference yeah
this is very good um so they're right
there in the center of town so they get
firemen they get policemen they get kids
from the high school people from all
over come from all over the country
actually to try this little restaurant
two little tables James Beard award
nominees when you ask were you worried
if if people would like Jamaican food
and he said no not worried at all at all
not at all
why why is that because people like good
food that's good food and it's a classic
American story American Dream you see a
little shop and you go one day I'm gonna
open up a business there it is and there
it is yeah we appreciate it thank you so
much